[Music]
for action anime fans there's nothing
more exciting than a good old fight and
who can resist those fast-paced battles
and the amazing skills of the animators
today I'm bringing to you the top 20
hand-to-hand combat moments in anime get
ready for some jaw-dropping fights and
intense showdowns that have kept fans
glued to their seats let's start things
off in the crazy world of psychopass
episode 16 gives us a mind-blowing
psychological Thriller when golgami
takes on the crafty Mastermind makishima
this battle is pure mind games they're
not just throwing punches but also
trading deep philosophical ideas it's
like a battle of wits with fists flying
so in their intense battle gogami lands
powerful blows on makishima driven by
anger and frustration but makishimas and
yielding belief in his ideals keeps him
going and despite gorgami's efforts he
manages to escape leaving kogami
grappling with feelings of failure and
the fight against the corrupt system but
hey don't let that go through you
because the animation and choreography
during their battle with top-notch they
really bring out the raw emotions of
these characters the way they fight is
intense and you can't take your eyes off
the screen for a second it's thrilling
suspenseful and keeps you on the edge of
your toes no wonder it's one of those
memorable moments in the whole
psychopath series
foreign
Series has gotten for its animation and
soundtrack one entry that often gets
overlooked is Apocrypha most people know
Apocrypha for more dread Jean anastolfo
but it also gave us one of the best
hand-to-hand battle scenes in the
franchise given how the franchise Prides
itself on historical figures and their
otherworldly Noble phantasms you'd be
surprised to see a straight up
hand-to-hand battle like this but it did
happen Two fighters in their decisive
battle gave us one of the best sequences
in fate Apocrypha with each impactful
blow the viewers get sucked into a very
immersive and Visually impressive fight
their final fights the well-deserved
payoff for Achilles journey in
overcoming his personal obstacle hey it
may not be a you for table show but fate
Apocrypha is an often overlooked gem
that deserves more love moving on we
have my hero Academia all might vs nomu
uh yes my hero Academia the season one
finale was a great one we got to witness
the epic showdown between Almighty nomu
and it was mind-blowing in their intense
battle nomu's Incredible strength and
multiple quirks makes him a tough nut to
crack although almight's power is
declining his unwavering determination
prevails The Clash of Titanic blows
creates shock waves leaving everyone
stunned in the end all might delivers
his plus Ultra punch that sends nomu
flying all might really showed us why
he's the world's Mightiest Hero he
didn't back down not even for a second
he went all out putting everything on
the line to take down nomu and protect
everyone it was a breathtaking display
of heroism and raw power I gotta admit
though that fight had me on the edge of
my seat the entire time all my sheer
determination and never give up attitude
was something else
okay
we have to talk about this epic fight
between gone and hisoka in Hunter Hunter
[Music]
so this showdown goes down during the
heavens Arena arc when gon's all pumped
up to take on hisoka who's been a real
pain in the butt throughout his
adventures gone's on a mission to show
everyone especially hisoka that he's a
force to be reckoned with gone's
determination is set on earning hisoka's
respect no matter what it takes and this
fight is a roller coaster of Thrills and
excitement gone brings his game relying
on his natural talents and instincts
he's quick agile and super resourceful
using every trick in the book to
outsmart his soccer and his deadly moves
but don't estimate hisoka either that
guy is a master tactician super
calculated and full of surprises he
loves messing with gone's head setting
traps left and right to gain the upper
hand but just when we thought the fight
was almost over gone pulled off this
crazy move unleashing his hidden then
power like a boss The Clash of their
abilities and personalities makes this
fight intense and emotionally charged
this battle is pure awesomeness and if
you haven't seen it yet then you are
missing out big time
[Music]
thank you
on to our next one let's talk about the
Epic visel fighting Festival Arc from
seven deadly sins
remember that mind-blowing slug Fest
between Immortal ban and the seven
deadly sins captain meliodas that fight
was nothing but an insane display of
their strength as the battle goes on we
get to see their unique Personalities in
action barns are all cheeky and carefree
while meliodas stays calm and composed
it's like a Clash of the Titans and it's
entertaining to watch the fight between
meliodas and barn is no doubt insane
they're going at it like crazy with
meliodas using his full counter to send
Barnes attacks back at him even harder
but Barn got a good with his immortality
and snatch ability stealing Powers left
and right and making himself a
Powerhouse while leaving his opponents
weakened but guess what meliodas pulls
off a surprising win turns out there's
this mysterious mark on his forehead
that was tested for a fraction of a
second and it totally tips the scales in
his favor you won't believe the secrets
this Mark holds but you've got to keep
watching to find out in the later
Seasons the animation certainly brings
out the intensity showing off the sheer
destructive power with every attack
[Music]
an oldie but a Goldie we have Hajime no
ippo ippo versus sawamura
[Music]
you can't talk about epic hand-to-hand
combat without mentioning the legendary
boxing anime Hajime no hippo the fight
between samamura and ippo is next level
intense for me samamura is hands down
one of ippo's toughest opponents
throughout the whole anime this fight is
the peak of sawamura storyline making it
even more awesome when you look at it in
that context Hajime no IPO keeps
bringing the heat with its epic fights
and this one is no exception ipo's
facing off against the craziest counter
puncher ever and he's a real psycho
hippo's unbeatable spirit and support
from his coach and friends give him the
upper hand but hey let's not forget how
sabamura tried to pull out some shady
moves it's no problem hippos are pro are
dodging that Foul Play Atlanta killer
final blow to claim the victory the
fight is long and packed with
jaw-dropping twists and moments making
it one of the best showdowns in the
entire series you've got to see it to
believe it Hajime no ippo totally rocks
the hand-to-hand combat scene when it
comes to anime fights it's one of the
kings in this department and that's
without a doubt
foreign
Drive brawler versus executioner
the Brawner versus executioner Showdown
was so unexpected but it turned out to
be one hell of an epic Clash that got
everyone hyped akodama Drive took its
sweet time to catch on but once he got
rolling he delivered a badass Vibe the
show set the mood just right from the
start but it took some time to hit its
peak and become the Talk of the Town
once it did though the fan following
exploded thanks to all that high stakes
drama and jaw-dropping battles it
brought to the table and that brawler
versus executioner fight it was one of
the best both of them were ready to go
all out risking everything for that
knockout finish even though the brawler
got hurt in their earlier scuffle he
still gave it his all and delivered a
killer final punch just like his
opponent he actually managed to take
each other down in the end the anime
just captured all that intense action
that made akudama drive so famous it was
an all-out War showcasing the brutal and
unforgiving world of akodama Drive where
strength and survival instincts are
everything
the Epic slugfest in Barky is between
yujiro hanma the strongest man on the
earth and Kaku Kayo a legendary martial
artist
this fight is pure raw power and skill
and it's insane in this crazy
underground Martial Arts Tournament
everyone knows it's going to be one hell
of a showdown the atmosphere is electric
with everyone holding their breath in
anticipation as their battle commenced
gaku Kayo pulled out his skills doing
all these crazy circular moves and
hitting yujiro from every direction hold
on yujiro isn't the one to back down he
counters with his pure Brute Force
throwing monster punches and kicks that
make the ground shake no wonder why he's
the strongest man on earth right it's a
real Clash of styles you've got Kaku
kaioshauri versus yujiro's Raw power
they're like a whirlwind of fists and
kicks tearing up the whole island in the
process but yujiro isn't done yet the
unleashes is in a beast mode and with a
colossal punch he takes down Kaku guyo
like a boss the animation is on fire in
this one capturing the intensity of
every blow you can practically feel the
impact through the screen and the
choreography hits a martial arts
Masterpiece showcasing their skills in a
mesmerizing dance of combat the battle
goes beyond just martial arts moves it's
like a exploration of strength character
and martial arts philosophy so if you're
into jaw-dropping fights in a
philosophical Journey barky's the way to
go
VV versus Hugo is next on our list
Vivi had some
momentum right from the start and know
one day it's connected to the Beloved
re-zero author the guy is a fan favorite
so you know it's going to be good it's a
bit of a wild ride diving into sci-fi
territory but hey it totally works out
in the end but when it comes to the
fights there sure are something else the
themes the quality and the pacing
everything is on point the series is
incredibly impressive and just picture
blending that exceptional quality with
some high-speed action Hugo and Vivi
engage in thrilling hand-to-hand combat
and the intensity is off the charts
however Yugo ultimately gets defeated by
the damage he's taken and in his final
moments Hugo shares a heartfelt
monologue with Vivi before passing away
the fight is packed with so much emotion
and it really tugs at your heartstring
it's why it's a gift to all anime fans
the combat is mind-blowing the animation
is crisp and clean and the music and
atmosphere just perfect
thank you
[Music]
and here we are we're finally halfway
through our list there are still more
great anime that'll blow your mind with
the hand-to-hand combat but first things
first make sure to like the video and
subscribe if you haven't done so yet
well well well Gintama makes it onto our
list and it's truly something special
it's an anime that's famous for its
hilarious comedy heartwarming stories
bunch of awesome characters
[Music]
now there are plenty of fights in the
series but one that really stands out in
hand-to-hand combat is the kamui vs
hosen Showdown the ball between gamma
Wii and hosen was nuts they were
Lightning Fast dodging each other's
attacks and throwing down some serious
strikes gamma always got this wicked
sadistic style keeping hosting on his
toes with brutal close range and
long-range moves but in the end neither
could take the other down and it just
ended up having mutual respect for each
other it's so cool that Gintama knows
how to balance the serious stuff with
the humor so in the midst of this
intense battle you'll find witty banter
and Hilarious Moments the light in the
mood it's their signature Gintama humor
that we all love this anime is a true
genre defying Masterpiece the gamoe vs
hosen fight is just one example of why
Gintama rocks and why fans all over the
world adore it
foreign
[Music]
that's got everyone hyped the fog Hill
of five elements one versus Assassin
[Music]
the full kill of five elements season
was already a total Banger and now
season two is here to keep us thirsty
for more Yep they're spoiling us with
another dose of stunning art story and
animation it's a visual Feast but let's
talk about the fight season two just
dropped and it's a combat Extravaganza
Schwan gets into an epic showdown with
an assassin and wow it's like something
out of a sci-fi movie The Fight is
intense every punch and kick packs a
serious punch gotta admit the Assassin's
fan as a weapon was pretty awesome too
but Schwan takes it to a whole new level
with this mind-blowing fire element
attack it's like the Firepower is off
the charts totally overwhelmingly
assassin and scoring the win in the end
I can't even express how awesome it
looks the fluidity of the animation is
Top Notch and you can feel the force
behind each blow it's like wow times a
hundred I could talk about this fight
all day that's how good it is Major
props to the animators they really
outdid themselves on this one it's a
visual masterpiece days with
action-packed goodness so don't sleep on
this one you've got to see it to believe
it
next you know what's coming Edward
versus greed in Full Metal Alchemist but
which one are we talking about we're
talking about the original Full Metal
Alchemist
[Music]
and this battle is next level Edward and
greed go all out trading some serious
blows and showing off their cool
abilities Edward gets all creative using
Earth walls and sneaky attacks while
greed's got this crazy strong shield and
lightning fast moves to counter the
fight keeps getting more intense with
Edward trying to figure out how to crack
Reed's defense pushing Edward to his
limits but then greed goes all
invulnerable with his ultimate Shield
form Edward isn't backing down he's
super sharp and finds a weak spot
Landing a devastating final attack that
takes greed down it sucks you right into
the world of Full Metal Alchemist this
fight between Edward Elric and greed is
a shining example of why this anime is
so brilliant it's deep it's emotional
and it captures all the complexities of
human nature and the tough moral
dilemmas faced by the characters if you
haven't watched it yet you really are
missing out on a true gem
[Music]
foreign
this wouldn't be a complete video
without mentioning the god of high
school especially the fight between Jin
Mori and Han Davey
fights are out of this world so
fast-paced and mind-blowing but out of
all the fights one really stood out it
was the brawl between Jin Mori and Han
Davy they were just throwing rapid fire
strikes to each other showing off their
awesome martial arts moves Jin mori's
Taekwondo was all about those crazy
kicks and punches while Han Davy style
was all precision and things got even
crazier when they Unleashed their final
blows Jin Mori with the Gin Mori
original blue dragon kick and Han Davey
with reverse as your dragon they were
throwing powerful punches and kicks but
in the end Jin mori's sheer strength
made him the winner he landed a decisive
blow knocking Han Dairy down and taking
the crown it's a turning point in their
character arcs and it's exciting to
watch too this anime has all the action
a compelling story and a diverse range
of characters God of high school just
keeps on captivating audience with its
stunning animation and epic battles
oh
my God
okay let's pick up this mind-blowing
showdown in Cowboy Bebop the movie
between Spike and Vincent
this neo-noir masterpiece takes the cake
with a battle that's pure Artistry and
emotion the combat kicks off with
lightning fast moves from Spike and
Vincent they're throwing all kinds of
kicks punches and crazy acrobatic moves
spikes like a tough nut to crack you
just won't give up even when Vincent's
packing some serious power the Spikes
have got more than broad he uses his wit
and skill to disarm Vincent setting up a
badass Showdown where he brings all his
strength to take down the
psychobioterrorist and stop the disaster
from happening it felt like you could
feel the intensity in every strike they
made showing off their incredible skills
but here's the real deal the animation
is on a whole other level it's not your
average fight sequence they mix in some
Artful Transitions and visual symbolism
making it feel like you're watching a
work of art in action the choreography
flows so smoothly between hand-to-hand
combat and Gunplay it's like watching a
cinematic Masterpiece unfold
foreign
next one it's the Dragon Ball series
Gogeta versus Broly
[Music]
it takes us on an exhilarating journey
through new Realms of power and
Adventure as one of the most highly
anticipated battles in the franchise the
showdown between Gogeta and Broly stands
as an epic highlight that leaves an
indelible mark on our memories in the
epic showdown Gogeta and Brody go all
out trading Lightning Fast punches and
kicks that shape the whole Battlefield
gogeta's got this smooth and fluid
combat star and he's like a master at
countering Broly's attacks but Broly
ain't holding back either showing off
his crazy raw power with non-stop
assaults that really put gogeta's
endurance to the test then things get
even better when Broly goes all
Legendary Super Saiyan but Goji defuses
his Super Saiyan blue with Kaio Ken and
it's like an explosion of energy and
power despite Broly's Relentless Fury
gogeta's key manipulation skills let him
outmaneuver him and he delivers this
epic final blow that ends the fight in
the most jaw-dropping way the
choreography during this battle was a
masterpiece showcasing the seamless
Fusion of Goku and Vegeta's moves into a
dazzling play of martial arts prowess
the conclusion of the battle leaves a
profound impact on both characters and
the fans the fusion of Goku and Vegeta
into Gogeta and Broly's transformation
into a Super Saiyan achieve a level of
power previously unseen in the Dragon
Ball franchise this fight remains etched
in the annals of Dragon Ball history as
a definitive moment that continues to
resonate with fans worldwide
[Applause]
[Music]
next up let's talk about the epic
showdown in one punch Man saithama
versus boros
she doesn't do it
the strongest dude around takes on boros
the Dominator of the universe it's like
an Unstoppable Force meets an immovable
object in their intense battle Boris
throws some serious energy blast
besidesh armor just zooms around dodging
them like a boss with his crazy speed
saitama is all about raw power and
devastating punches while Boris comes
back with quick moves in regenerative
tricks but what's really wild is when
saithama finally takes the fight
seriously and busts out his serious
series serious punch and borrows his
regenerative Powers they go down the
drain so after all that craziness Boris
finally throws in the towel and admits
that saitama is the real deal The
Ultimate Warrior that concluding brawl
in one punch man was totally epic it's
like a visual Masterpiece showing off
saitama's insane strength and borrows
his killer skills even though boros gave
it his all to challenge like Dharma he
finally gets it and there's just no
beating the unrivaled power of the one
punch man
[Music]
now we have another classic Luffy versus
Luchi in one piece
laughs
in addition to the emotional context and
the weight of the fight I'd say that the
battle against Lucy's one of Luffy's
fights that is all about his raw power
for a lot of fights Luffy receives help
in true Shonen fashion whether it be
surviving crocodile's initial assaults
through luck or law helping out against
doflamingo and others however this
battle against Lucci's a good old
physical brawl that barring some
motivations from Usopp basically is a
battle that Luffy won through effort not
a lot of plot related devices going on
around to help Luffy secure the win and
we're treated to a nice little slugfest
that features the two combatants
answering each other with blazingly hard
punches and physical feats
[Music]
let's move on to the action-packed anime
hitori no shita Oya versus the masked
outcast
foreign
this intense battle between Oya and the
Mysterious Mast Outcast is a total
Thrill Ride when the brawl starts oh
yeah goes all out showing off his badass
martial arts skills with fast kicks and
precise punches straight out of
traditional Chinese martial arts but hey
the Mast outcasts ain't no slouches
either they come back at him with their
elemental powers trying to mess him up
but oh yeah's got guts and heart he
doesn't back down even for a second as
the fight goes on Oya unleashes his
crazy power that totally rocks the
battlefield those masked outcasts can't
keep up with him and in the end he
ultimately proved himself that he's too
much for the outcast to handle and now
let's talk animation it's off the charts
the raw intensity of the battle is right
there on the screen every punch and kick
is just mind-blowing in detail the
animators really killed it with this one
the choreography is on point two each
character has their own unique fighting
style and it's like a visual Feast for
the eyes and get this the guy behind the
fight choreography also did the Epic
Naruto and Sasuke vs momoshiki fight the
Face-Off between
is definitely one for the books it's a
standout moment in hitori noshita the
outcast and it will leave you with a
lasting impression trust me you won't
forget this epic duel anytime soon
foreign
is the most hyped and anticipated anime
in the Modern Age Jiu Jitsu Kaizen Yuji
and Toto versus Hanami and it totally
lives up to the hype because this anime
is absolutely spectacular
speaking of fights that fight between
Yuji Toto and Hanami was off the charts
in the first season Yuji was a beast
showing off his crazy physical prowess
and teaming up with suguna's cursed
energy for some mind-blowing attacks and
Toto's Boogie Woogie technique was
magical dodging Hanami strikes and
Landing Some solid counter blows Hanami
wasn't holding back either using his
plant control to unleash some deadly
Vines and Roots but Yuji and Toto's
teamwork was on point coordinating their
attacks like pros and that black flash
was the icing on the cake dealing a
massive hit to Hanami but hold up we
can't even say who won because Gojo who
was Miles Away swoops in and shows off
his badass abilities Jiu Jitsu Kaizen is
a true Masterpiece when it comes to
fights the characters the fight the
animation everything is amazing and
season 2 is airing right now and you
know there'll be more mind-blowing
fights coming our way
thank you
Obito versus Kakashi is here once again
and we have to partly thank the Builder
for that Builders ninjas at the top of
their game as well as having an entire
mini Arc dedicated to their past not
only is the battle a very well built up
one with an intense backstory and hype
it's also Peak hand-to-hand combat in
Naruto the animation team spared no
expense here and the flurry of exchanges
got encapsulated thanks to their hard
work make no mistake though the battle
within kamui is a feast for the eyes and
you'd be missing out if you didn't watch
it if there's a fight to watch the
entire series of Naruto 4 in terms of
animation and Pace that is this would
surely be one of those
and that wraps up the video now I want
to hear from you which moment from this
list is your favorite did I miss any
awesome hand-to-hand combat scenes that
you think should be included share your
thoughts and I'll catch you in the next
video